and really with my number seven choice
for a very particular reason I felt like
I was this character at least to some
extent it's Jane from Daria which I know
might shock some of you as you may think
I would just automatically go for a
Daria as one of my favorite characters
she is the star of the show and in many
respects probably the most complex but
for almost purely selfish reasons I
relate more with Jane because I felt I
was more like Jane I was sort of as
smart as artists who just want to be
left alone to draw whenever I could
which is not to say it didn't talk to
anyone I found those few select people
that I didn't want to discuss things
with but oftentimes just being in a room
working on a piece of art can be just as
rewarding as going out some night with
friends and Jane seemed to be a big fan
of that too she wasn't quite die-hard
miserable as Daria was she actually
enjoyed the human experience
which yeah Daria what at times to but be
very reluctant Jane would still enjoy
something different and be open to new
possibilities which is not to say she
wasn't a cynic she was but she could
also find joy in things and I really
appreciated that like many kids my age I
was not a fan of high school the fact
that I had to return to this place five
times a week rather than just bitch and
moan about it I thought yeah turn into
some artwork see if I can grow myself in
various ways of expression which of
course I didn't know I was doing at the
time but who does at that age and yeah a
lot of the artwork was pretentious just
like Jane's work was but we were still
learning but enough about how similar we
are because if I had to be truly honest
I knew that it wasn't just Jane that was
Amy but very much up Chuck yeah as much
as I hate to a minute I knew he was in
me too in my dream memories I was Jane
but in reality I knew I was Jane and
upchuck geeky awkward and sometimes too
egotistical but screw it I knew the
elements of Jane is what I admired the
most and when prey I was more like her
than I was up Chuck she was always that
perfect complement to Daria because she
was never completely against reality she
just questioned it Daria always seemed
closed off to anything new and sometimes
she was right but other times she was
wrong
at least give new things a chance
whether it be people events or even job
opportunities Daria would eventually
learn that too but it took her a little
longer and maybe that's why she was the
focus of the show you could see much
more of the journey but I admire Jane -
for how much she did know about herself
but also how much she didn't and yet
still had to respond to it a lot of
people have a huge backlash when daria
actually gets a boyfriend but i really
enjoy it because it shows the dynamics
between two really good friends and yeah
the boyfriend is bland and way too
perfect that did bother me and it did
force daria to make way too many
mistakes and him always being right that
kind of pissed me off too but i like the
conversations that came out of it
I liked that it showed that a friendship
can be so strong that it can last this
but at the same time it still created
that doubt it created those questions
and those times are gonna happen in
really close friendships and the fact
that both of them could find the
maturity to find somewhere to be
reasonable especially in high school
show signs of really good qualities from
all the characters and the fact that the
writing can do it well enough where it
never quite seemed force it actually did
seem believable enough is also very
impressive I think love triangles when
they're play for drama almost always
crash and burn but the fact that these
two had such a good friendship and would
actually discuss it and talk about it as
maturely as two high schoolers screw it
two people could really show that there
was some great characters here and Jane
was by far my favorite cynical and funny
but still open to the new Jane is the
high school artist I always wanted to be
even though I probably wasn't
you